THE COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. WITH FACE COVERINGS
AND THOSE GUIDELINES COMPLIANCE
WITH THOSE ORDERS SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
STRONG PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC CONTINUES
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. WITH MOST MEMBERS
PRESENT OTHERS FORTHCOMING. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
MANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TUTORING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENT
ALLOWS IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE RIVERS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PURCHASE MENTAL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE ARE POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. JEEZ
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE FIVE
FOUR NINE ZERO. THAT IS EIGHT
FOUR NINE ZERO. IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS NINE SEVEN SIX.
308-797-6308 SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECOM SYSTEM WORKS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE.
CANTOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY MODERATE JULY
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PERSISTS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PTIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE RELY NUMBER
YOU WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON
MUTE IN YOUR NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. IN AN INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. ALL EVERY
EFFORT IS MADE TO STREAMLINED
HEARING PROCESS. AND CONDUCT
OUR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE. TO
THE SAME MATTER MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES ARE PARTICIPANTS
WERE JUSTIN TWO. NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IN
PATIENTS ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
CAN BE HEARD. ON TODAY'S AGENDA
WE HAVE TWO BILLS BEFORE WE
PROCEED WITH THE GENDER LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM AT
THIS MOMENT THE WE ARE WAITING
ON ONE OF OUR NEXT MEMBERS.
KENTUCKY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FORGE'S PRESENT PORTARO
CABALLERO. EGGMAN GLAZER. ALL
RIGHT AND THERE'S A QUORUM. FOR
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CONSEILLER
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTS OF
ONE BILL FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
S. B. EIGHT ONE FIVE BY THE
SENATE AG COMMITTEE. DO I HAVE
A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THERE IS BEEN A
MOTION. BY CENTER EGGMAN
CONSOLE GAME PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTING OF ITEM NUMBER TWO
SB EIGHT FIFTEEN BARGES FIVE.
OR JUST HI HER TADO. HURTADO HI
CABALLERO. EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE. ALL
RIGHT THAT IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS FIVE OWES IN ZERO
KNOWS BUT WE'LL PUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL AS WE WAIT OUR
COLLEAGUE. ALL RIGHT LET'S HEAR
FROM OUR- SINGLE AUTHOR TODAY.
SENATOR ALLEN YOU HAVE ONE BILL
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB TWO THREE FIVE
THE LECTERN IS YOURS WHAT ARE
YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND MEMBERS
ITS IT'S- NICE TO BE HERE I- I
DON'T OFTEN COME TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE WHEN I
DO. WHEN I DO I LIKE TO BRING
YOU COULD BILL SO THIS IS S. B.
TWO THIRTY FIVE- WHICH BRINGS
LEGAL CLARITY AND STRICT
REGULATIONS- ON THE MANUFACTURE
SALE AND USE OF HEMP DERIVED
PRODUCTS. IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA SO FOR THOSE THAT
DON'T KNOW HALF IS A PLANT
GROWING PROCESS THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD FOR THOUSANDS OF CONSUMER
GOODS INCLUDING FOOD AND
TEXTILES. COSMETICS BODY CARE
I'D ITEMS PAPER. IN FACT SOME
OF OUR FOUNDING DOCUMENTS ARE
ACTUALLY- DRAFTED ON HEMP
PAPER- ONE OF THE MOST COMMONLY
KNOWN INGREDIENTS DRIVING
HABITS I CANNABIS OIL. WHICH IS.
CALLING ON CBD A NON
PSYCHOACTIVE DERIVATIVE- WITH
NO THC. NOW AS PERMITTED UNDER
FEDERAL LAW. EARLY MORE THAN
HALF OF ALL STATES IN THE
COUNTRY PERMITTED HEMP CBD TO
BE INCLUDED AS AN INGREDIENT IN
FOOD BEVERAGES DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS. CALIFORNIA ARE YOU
PERMITS AND CAREFULLY REGULATES
THE MANUFACTURE AND SALE OF
CANNABIS. DERIVED CBD PRODUCTS
REMEMBER THAT THE ONLY
DISTINCTION BETWEEN CANNABIS
AND HEMP IS THE LEVEL OF THC-
IN THE PLANT HOWEVER THE
STATE'S LAWS RELATED TO HEMP
DERIVED PRODUCTS ARE MURKY SO
IN RECENT YEARS THE COVER ABOUT
A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE THE
NUMBER OF- OF NOTICES OF
VIOLATION VOLUNTARY
CONDEMNATION AND DESTRUCTION
LETTERS EMBARGOES RELATED TO
HEMP DERIVED CBD PRODUCTS SO
ARE THE CONVERSATION DEBATE
SACRAMENTO ABOUT HABITS NOW
ENTERING ITS THIRD YEAR I'M
AUTHORED THIS PROPOSAL IN
PARTNERSHIP A CELL NUMBER
AGUILAR CURRY TO GIVE THE
SENATE AMPLE TIME AND
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON THE
POLICY AND HOPEFULLY IMPROVE.
UPON A STATUS QUO THAT DEPRIVED
THE HEMP INDUSTRY INCLUDING
THOSE BUSINESSES LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA FROM COMPETING ON A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WITH OVER
HALF OF ALL U. S. STATES. NOW
THIS LEGISLATION HEARD AND PASS
OUT OF THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WITH UNANIMOUS.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT- THIS
COMMITTEE AND ITS MEMBERS ARE
PROPERLY SO HAVE BEEN FOCUSED
ON HOW THE BILL IMPACTS
CALIFORNIA'S. AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY. I SPOKE EXTENSIVELY
WITH THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE LAST NIGHT- AND- AND
GAVE HIM A COMMITMENT. IN
PERSON. THAT I WANT TO PUBLICLY
MAKE TO YOU TODAY IN FRONT OF
THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THE CONCERNS HE RAISED. TO
ME. ARE LARGELY THE CONCERNS
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU ARE
SHARED BY- BYE BYE BYE FOR THE
REST OF THIS COMMITTEE AND SO-
LET ME JUST MENTION THAT THE
KEY ISSUES. THE FIRST ISSUE HAS
TO DO WITH THE TESTING OF HAM
FOR TOTAL THC CONTENT AND-
PERMITTING A MEASUREMENT OF
UNCERTAINTY. THAT'S A COMMON
STANDARD IT'S FEDERALLY DEFINED
pACHIEVED BY DIFFERENT TESTING
INSTRUMENTATION. AND FACILITIES
NOW I'M ABSOLUTE COMMITTED TO
RESOLVING THIS ISSUE- TO THE
FARM BUREAU'S SATISFACTION. AND
WE'RE STARTING THOSE. ARE THE
SECOND ISSUE IS A PROPOSED ZERO
TOLERANCE STANDARD FOR
CONTAMINANTS WHICH IS ARGUABLY.
APPROPRIATE FOR THE CANNABIS
PLANT. WHICH IS NOT FEDERALLY
APPROVED TO BE TREATED WITH
PESTICIDES THE FARM BUREAU
WOULD LIKE TO THE FRONT OF THE
CALIPHATE HAVE LATITUDE TO
EXAMINE AN ISSUE. HEALTH AND
SAFETY REGULATIONS THAT IT
DECIDES ARE APPROPRIATE FOR
HELP. WHICH IS FEDERALLY
APPROVED TO BE TREATED WITH
CERTAIN PESTICIDES THIS SEEMS
REASONABLE TO ME- AND I AM
AGAIN COMMITTED TO RESOLVING
THE ISSUE TO THE FARM BUREAU
SATISFACTION. THE FINAL ISSUE
IS WHETHER OR NOT TO PROHIBIT
HIM FROM BEING SOLD. IN A
SMOKABLE ARE INHALABLE FORM-
THERE IS SERIOUS DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT THIS ISSUE WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE- I THINK WE WILL
HAVE A REAL TROUBLEGETTING OUT
OF HEALTH COMMITTEE QUITE
FRANKLY IF WE HAD- YOU KNOW.
I'VE OPENED THE FLOODGATES FOR
THE FOR THAT- BUT I'M CERTAINLY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW POSSIBLY
TO FIND COMMON GROUND. WITHIN
OUR OWN SENATE FAMILY INCLUDES
EVEN WITHIN THE TWO COMMITTEES-
TO FIND SOME COMMON GROUND THAT
MIGHT LEAD TO A DIFFERENT
PROPOSAL THAN WHAT IS BEFORE
YOU TODAY- NOW. HI I DO ASK ON
ALL THREE OF THESE CONCERNS
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
AT TODAY'S WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE BILL AS IT APPEARS IN
PRINCE OF THAT WE CAN SEEK
RESOLUTION DURING CONVERSATIONS
THE MINISTRATION WHICH OF
COURSE. HAS ITS OWN FEELINGS
ABOUT ALL THIS. AN ALTERNATELY
I WANNA ARRIVE AT A FRAMEWORK
TO THIS GOVERNOR WILL SIGN AND
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH FEEL
COMFORTABLE THEY CAN IMPLEMENT-
MY STAFF AND I ALSO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OPPOSITION FROM A
NUMBER OF CANNABIS RETAILERS
INCLUDING SOME WITHIN MY OWN
DISTRICT IN. THE DISTRICTS OF
SOME MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I'M ACTUALLY OPEN- TO WORKING
CONSTRUCTIVELY WITH THIS
COALITION SPECIFICALLY I'D LIKE
CANNABIS RETAILERS TO BE ABLE
TO SELL. HEMP DERIVED PRODUCTS
ONE THING THEY TALK ABOUT A LOT
OF PARITY- AND CERTAINLY UNDER
THE CURRENT SCHEME THEY WOULD.
NOT BE ABLE TO SELL. UNDER
UNDER CURRENT LAW THERE THEY
ARE PROHIBITED FROM SELLING NON
PSYCHOACTIVE- HAVE DERIVED
PRODUCTS AND- AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S FAIR SO WE HAVE WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD FIGURE OUT A
WAY. TO FIND PARITY ON THAT. AT
NOW ARE I WILL SAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTIVELY
ENGAGE THEY OF COURSE HAVE
STRONG FEELINGS AND SO WE'VE
GOT TO. ADDRESS THIS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THEM SO AGAIN
I ASK YOUR INDULGENCE TO MOVE
FOR TODAY. SO JOIN ME TODAY AS
WE WITNESS WE HAVE RAN MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE U. S. HEMP
ROUNDTABLE AND ALSO ATTY.
BERNACCHI FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HEMP COUNCIL. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU CENTER ELEMENT- WILL NOT BE
MOVING ON TO TESTIMONY DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS. REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS. THE
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MAINSTREET TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED NICKEL MOUNTAIN TIME
TO BE DETERMINED BY THE CHAIR.
THE LIMIT WILL BE. TWO TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. EACH
WITNESS ALLOWED TO MISS TO
TESTIFY. ALL THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURES- CENTER ALLEN'S
FIRST WITNESS. WITNESS AS HE
MENTIONED IS MISTER RAND MARTIN
REPRESENTING. THE U. S. HEMP
ROUNDTABLE. AND MISTER MARTIN
IS PHYSICALLY PRESENT ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE MISTER
MARTIN PLEASE BEGIN. HE WAS
SHARE MEMBERS AGAIN RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF U. S. HEMP
ROUNDTABLE. I'M ALSO HERE
REPRESENTING KHALIFA WHICH IS A
CANNABIS COMPANY BASED OUT OF
SAN JOSE. THERE ARE THREE
OBJECTIVES THAT WE HAVE WITH
THIS BILL- AFTER AS SENATE
ALLEN INDICATED. NEARLY THREE
YEARS OF WORKING ON THIS ISSUE.
NUMBER ONE IS THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE THIS INDUSTRY LEGAL IT IS
PARTIALLY LEGAL UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
TOPICALS AND CREAMS. IT IS NOT
LEGAL FOR FOOD AND BEVERAGE
DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS OR PET
PRODUCTS. AND ALL THE ECONOMIC
PROJECTIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
SAY THAT THOSE ARE THE PRODUCTS
WHERE. WHAT THE CONSUMERS
REALLY WANT TO GRAVITATE
TOWARDS OVER THE OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS AND WOULD LIKE
CALIFORNIA TO BE THERE AS WELL.
NUMBER TWO THERE ARE REALLY
GREAT ACTORS AND HIM DENTISTRY
NOW. SOME NOT SO GREAT IN TERMS
OF CONSUMER SAFETY AND CONSUMER
WARNINGS. THIS BILL NOW CREATES
A VERY ROBUST REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK- FOR CONSUMER SAFETY.
IT HAS TESTING PARITY WITH
CANNABIS TESTING. IT HAS
LABELING PARITY WITH A CANNABIS
LABELING INTER INCLUDING THINGS
LIKE. A WARNING THAT- THAT
PREGNANT WOMEN OR BREAST
FEEDING WOMEN. SHOULD CONSULT
WITH A PHYSICIAN. THE THIRD
OBJECTIVE OF THIS BILL RIGHT
NOW IS TO GENERATE SOME
ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO THE
STATE. AGAIN IT'S BEEN NEARLY.
THREE YEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE. IN THAT
TIME TO NINE STATES HAVE AHEAD
OKAY. YOU TERMS OF LEGALIZING
CBD AND ALL OF THESE PRODUCTS.
THEYARE THEY ARE BENEFITING
FROM THE TAX REVENUES OF THIS
BRAND NEW. ARRAY OF PRODUCTS
THAT CALIFORNIA IS NOT- AND
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT HAPPEN
WITH WITH THE TAX REVENUES
WITHIN THE JOBS CREATED. AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THIS IS A
TIME WHEN WE CAN OBVIOUSLY USE.
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS INTO OUR
STATE- ARE SPUR STATE COFFERS.
WE LIKE THE SENATOR ARE
ACTUALLY COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH BOTH THE FARM BUREAU AND
SOME OF THE CANVAS INTERESTS
WHO HAVE EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS. WE COMPLETELY SUPPORT
CANNABIS BEING ALLOWED TO. BE
INCLUDED IN THE CAMP HI I'VE
GOT SUPPLY CHAIN WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE FARM BUREAU AND ALL
THE THINGS THAT THEY REQUEST
AND ARE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. I'M IN WITH
YOUR SENATE COLLEAGUES AND USED
TO WORK TO ACHIEVE THOSE SIX WE
APPRECIATE. YOUR TIME AND AFTER
I'VE OF TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MUCH MORE. A CENTER ON
SECOND WITNESS- MISTER EDDIE
BERNACCHI REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA HEMP COUNCIL. IS
SHOULD BE ON THE COASTLINE
MODERATOR. CAN YOU PLEASE.
CONFIRM MISTER BERNACCHI IS IN
THE QUEUE. IT'S GOING TO. THANK
YOU I. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
I- COMMITTEE. ANYWHERE NACCHIO
MAPPING CALIFORNIA NOW- WHICH
IS A COALITION OF THE
CALIFORNIA BASED TEMPLE
DEBATERS PRODUCT MANUFACTURERS
AND DISTRIBUTORS- SB TWO THIRTY
FIVE OF THE VITAL MEASURE TO
ENSURE THE CONTINUED TO. HAVE
BEEN A DREAM CALIFORNIA.
FOLLOWING THE ISSUANCE OF A
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH I THANK YOU IN JULY OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. WHICH IT
PROHIBITED THE USE OF TAMPER
RIDE NAVIN AWAIT YOU- THE
BEVERAGES. OUR IT MAY MERGING
INDUSTRIES THOUGHT. YELLING A
PRACTICE BROUGHT EVERY BIBLE.
IT'S A PARTICULARLY FELT MARY
OF CULTIVATION WHICH LOTS OF
SIGNIFICANT OUTLET FOR THEIR
FINAL MATCH. AT THIS BILL SB
TWO THIRTY FIVE THREE
AUTHORIZES THE USE OF HEMP
DERIVED CANNABINOIDS IN FOOD
AND BEVERAGES- AND IN DOING SO
WILL CREATE SIGNIFICANT PATH
FORWARD FOR YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
FARMERS. AND CULTIVATORS TO
EXPAND AND HAVE BEEN HISTORY.
IN ADDITION THE BILL CREATE A
REGULATORY STRUCTURE AS MISTER
MARK MICHAEL PARKER A REFERENCE.
BUDGET BROUGH BY- THANK YOU.
RELATED TO HAVE DERIVED
PRODUCTS TESTING LABELING AND
INHERENT TO THE SHERMAN ACT AND
CURRENT GOOD MANUFACTURING
PRACTICE. UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
YOU THEY HAVE JOBS ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ROBUST
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS PROVISIONS
AND- I'LL CLOSE BY SAYING THAT
THEY COUNT THEMSELVES ALSO
LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR I TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ON HOW TO CREATE A
SIMILAR. FRAMEWORK FOR STATE
NON NICOTINE SMOKABLE HEMP
PRODUCTS IN THE STATE AND WE DO
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES THAT
THAT AREA PRESENTS- BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A EARNEST
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS SO WITH THAT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. TWO THIRTY
FIVE AND- DRIVE. THANK YOU MISS
WE'RE NOT ON MOVE ON TO THE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT AND SUPPORT IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEING
NONE- ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM-
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
SUPPORT SB TWO THREE FIVE. ONCE
AGAIN IT'S OVERFLOWING THE LINE
IS SO LONG CENTER. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE ON TO A WITNESS
WAITING TESTIFIED SUPPORT VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR ANYONE
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YES THE
CHAIRPERSON ONE AND IF YOU WISH
OR PRESS. I WANT. BUT THIS TIME
I'M SORRY CAN YOU HAVE STATE
THAT ONE MORE TIME I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE COMING IN AND OUT. MY
APOLOGIES. YES IF YOU ARE IN
GOOD FOR. A ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER EIGHT. IF I HAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN THIS IS A
BRUTAL TRICKLED. YEAH FOR YOU
NOT PUT A COMMERCIAL WORKERS.
SUPPORTER COMMANDED POSITION
PROBABLY ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THE RETAILERS TO LISTEN LATER
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
COMMENTS REGARDING. AND NOW I'M
TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE KNOW
COME UP WITH SOME SOLUTION TO
THE ISSUE OF. DON'T
INTOXICATION LEVELS AND TO THE
TESTIMONY IS ANOTHER. PROJECT
BUT ONCE WONDER. NOT ONLY
OFFICIALS. ARE THANK YOU.
MODERATED WE HAVE FIVE MORE
CALLS. YES NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP THE- BY HAND CAN YOU
GIVE US AN IDEA HOW MANY FOLKS
ARE IN THE QUEUE. WE HAVE THREE
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU.
AND LINE NUMBER SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING THIS
IS AMBER MARC COULD NOT CALL
CANNABIS COMPANY WE ARE AT.
WITH THE FOR AT EIGHT THIRTY
FIVE AM AND THEN. CURRENTLY THE
BILL PROPOSED IN THE REPORT THE
GOVERNOR WHICH REQUIRES
REGULATORS OUTLINED THE
NECESSARY TO ALLOW CORPORATIONS
AND- INTO THE SUPPLY IN THE
CANNABIS SUPPLY CHANCE. STORE
AND THEY DON'T CANNABIS
OPERATORS ARE ONLY CONSIDERED
WHEN CONTEMPLATING HAND AND THE
CANNABIS THE FIGHT JAMES WE
REQUEST THE REPORT BE OFFENDED
BUT THE FOLLOWING. A DETAILED
ANALYSIS OF THE POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC IMPACT BLATANT
CANNABIS OPERATORS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN BE
INCORPORATED. INTO YOUR I CAME.
MATTHEW BERRY FIVE LEVINE
POLICY AND- GOING ON OKAY FOR
CANNABIS BY THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN. I AM THRILLED THAT OF
BIRTH THE LIFE. DELIGHTS
TWENTY. TO ALLOW REGULATORS.
POPULATION AT WHAT IT IT AT
WHAT CAME BACK. OUT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU IN MODERATE
YOU PLEASE REFER FOLKS THE WE
ARE ASKING FOR THEIR OF PHILLY
AND POSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
FOR SOMEONE CAN YOUR NAME YOUR-
MISSION. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER HE'S CALL AHEAD.
MORE MISTER CHAIR MEMBER AND
STAMP BUT TAMPA NOT BY. AFTER
THE PROMOS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND WILL UP FIFTEEN WILL
BE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DEVINE BY THAT
BUYS ON THE OF THE CANOPY
GROWTH CORP IN STOCKS. AND AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIRPERSON WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE AND- OKAY. ALL
RIGHT- HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS AND HELPFUL THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS. LISTED FOR SB TWO
THREE FIVE CAN WE CONFIRM THAT
IS STILL ACCURATE. CURRENT CARD
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEING
NONE- MOVING OVER INTO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IF YOU CAN QUEUE UP
THE VIDEO THERE WE GO SEEING
NONE OVER THERE- WATER YOU'RE
GONNA BE MOVING BACK ON TO-
WITNESSES WAY JUST FIVE VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICES IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO THREE
FIVE. IF YOU COULD REMIND
CALLERS TO STATE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE. IN A MINUTE YOU
DO SPECIAL OPPOSITION COURT.
THIRTY FIVE THE STATE YOUR NAME.
CHECK ONE ZERO YOU ARE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE NUMBER. AT.
HI GOOD MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU YOU
HAVE BEEN A CLOSE AMENDED FOR
THE READING SENATOR VERY APTLY
ARTICULATED I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR PER BRING
BILLBOARD IN THE INTEREST OF
OUR HEMP GROWERS AT THE
CERTAINLY FOR THE SENATORS.
CREATE A LEGAL PATHWAY ALL
RIGHT ABOUT THAT AND IN
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO BE DONE
NOW IN A WAY IT REMAINS
ACCEPTABLE FOR CALIFORNIA
FARMERS WE TOTALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT CHALLENGES OF LOCAL
HAMPTON AND ISSUES AROUND THAT
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
OTHERS ON THAT. ONE ITEM TO BE
CONSIDERED UNDER WILL BE AT OUR
IN OUR DEAL AND FORCE MEN ALL
RAFEAL OUR BUILDER CAL WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE IT'S NOT
MISINTERPRETED AS INTENDED FOR
SMOKING AND CAN BE USED AND A
HOST OF WAY IT'S INCLUDING
THOSE HAVE NOT THOUGHT OF THAT.
AND MY CLOTHES. BACK OR- AT ON
THE WHOLE THE BILL. AND WILL TO
WITH AND IN THE BILL SPONSORS
WE ATE THERE ON THE- THAT. OF
MY- THANK YOU. MOTOR CAN YOU
GIVE ASIDE HOW MANY ARE IN THE
QUEUE. YES WE HAVE THREE A THIS
TIME. COME NEXT WEEK TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY BUT. IN LINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE NUMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHN DONOVAN CIRCLE I WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE A LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS BUT I HAVE BEEN
GIVEN PERMISSION TO LIST ON A
PUBLIC COMMITMENT.
ORGANIZATIONS ARE UNITED
CANNABIS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
SANTA ANA CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION.
LONG BEACH COLLECTIVE
ASSOCIATION. COLUSA COUNTY
ALLIANCE. HELLO VALLEY CANNABIS
EQUITY LOS ANGELES WE HAVE NOT
WOOD COUNTERBALANCE TO HIS
OFFICE LOOK FORTY HEARING BACK
FROM THE SPENDERS OFFICE ON OUR
MENU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AN
EXTRA LINE NUMBER ELEVEN AT.
GOOD MORNING I'M NOT SURE
NUMBERS GRAYSON BRYANT ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY PERSONAL
LINES. MR DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION UP THERE IS ATION
EVAN OPPOSED. ADDITION ON S. B.
TWO THIRTY FIVE AND APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF.
MET TO ADDRESS BUT- LOOKING
FORWARD. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP. BUT. BY NUMBER TWENTY
ONE YEAR OLD. YES HELLO MR CARE
MEMBERS. ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
COOL. REPRESENTING FIVE
REGIONAL. MENDOCINO CANNABIS
FIND CREEK ALLIANCE- HARVARD'S
SB IT'S PRETTY COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL. GROWER'S ALLOW.
IN OPPOSITION THIS MEASURE READ
THAT HAVE BRINGING STATED OR TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR. DO YOU
HAVE A AUDIO YOU HAVE A ECHO ON
MY IT IS FOR YOUR QUALITY ANY
ALL IN- ON THE. THANK YOU
BRIGHTER IMMEDIATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING TO OUR
TEN. WATER DO WE HAVE A ANY
OTHER. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
OTHERS ALL RIGHT- YEAH I DO
THAT WE HAD SOME TECH ISSUES
BUT IT HASN'T KEPT ANYONE FROM
PARTICIPATING IT'S JUST NOT AS
CLEAR CONVENIENT. EXACTLY. YEAH
IT'S FINE DINING BEING.
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATIONS HAVE
BEEN SATISFIED. ALL RIGHT-
SEEING NO OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE WERE
GONNA BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK- TO OUR MEMBERS- I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE LIBERTY I THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR SPENDING A GOOD
AMOUNT OF TIME WITH ME
YESTERDAY GOING THROUGH- SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY A
VARIETY OF- AND ORGANIZATIONS
AND DOES HE MENTION EARLIER- HI
HE WILL BE CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSIONS. WITH THESE FOLKS
WITH THE IDEA OF-ALLOWING FOR
FEDERAL REGULATION CONSISTENCY.
AND THEN OF COURSE YOU KNOW THE
TOLERANCE LEVEL FOR PESTICIDE
RESIDUE- AND HOW THAT DEALS
WITH- WITH- WITH TESTING. OF
HEMP. AND IT I DIDN'T FEEL IT
WAS NECESSARY TO- TO PUT
FORWARD FORMAL AMENDMENTS
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
BE MOVING IN THAT RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND YOU OF COURSE
YOU GET THE STANDING. AND IN
THE END YOUR WERE DISCUSSED IS
GOING TO CONTINUE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS COLLEAGUES- ANY
OTHER. I WAS CONSIDERED SECOND
TIME I'VE I'VE HEARD THIS BILL
WE HEARD AND HEALTH AND
CERTAINLY THE ISSUES ARE ARE
DIFFERENT HERE. BUT I TRUST THE
OTHERS GOING TO KEEP WORKING
WITH THE WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND I WOULD MOVE THIS BILL ALL
RIGHT CENTER THE- CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU I CHAIR I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
STEPPING INTO THE SPACE AND
TRYING TO WORK OUT AT. AND NOT
ISSUE. BUT AN IMPORTANT ONE
YOU'VE DONE THAT TO YOUR YOUR
WHOLE. SERVICE HERE IN THE
SENATE WE APPRECIATE TO IN IN
THE SPACE IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU
IN FRONT OF THE- AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE. BUT I KNOW THAT YOU
OUR FRIEND OF AGRICULTURE WE
BOTH GOT OUR SHOES DIRTY. TWO
YEARS AGO- WALKING THROUGH THE
FARMS AND RANCHES AND PACKING
HOUSES OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
TOGETHER. AND THAT. IT SHOULD
YOUR COMMITMENT TO TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND ALL SIDES OF ISSUES
AND I KNOW. THAT YOUR FRIEND
OF- OF THE FARMER NOT THAT YOU
AGREE ON EVERY ISSUE WE AGREE
ON ALL THE ISSUES BUT YOU'RE
VERY COMMITTED TO. TO FIGURE
THESE THINGS OUT AND APPRECIATE
THE IMPORTANT VALUE THAT
AGRICULTURE BRINGS TO OUR
STATE. TO OUR WORKERS. HE MADE
A COMMENT IN YOUR OPENING THAT
I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT. AND
THAT IS YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
COMPETITIVENESS THE NEED TO BE
COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER STATES.
AND A LOT OF TIMES IN THIS
SPACE W- WE STRUGGLE BECAUSE
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THE
PERFECT- AND YET- AND THAT'S A
GREAT GOAL TO TRY TO. WORK ON
AND A WHOLE HOST OF AREAS BUT-
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT- OUR
OUR FARMERS ARE OUT THERE
COMPETING. WITH OTHERS IN OTHER
STATES AND WE HAVE TO BE
SENSITIVE TO THAT I THANK YOU
FROM THE COLLEGE THAT. I KNOW
THAT IT WILL BE PART OF THAT.
THE THOUGHT FOR YOU WORK YOU DO
TO TRY. TO RESOLVE THESE
REMAINING ISSUES AND I. RESHARE
COMMITTEE THAT YOU HAVE A TODAY
AND I. TO SUPPORT BILL. YOU CAN.
THE TOTALING SIX. CABALLERO
THANK YOU ARE SENATE ALLEN FOR
BRING THIS BILL FOR AND MUCH
LIKE MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM A
STOCKTON MENTIONED I ALSO
SUPPORTED THE BILL AN INCIDENT
HEALTH AND OBVIOUSLY THE ISSUES
ARE DIFFERENT HERE- YOU KNOW I
TAKE. AND MUCH LIKE MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM A- THE REMOTE.
CONTRA COSTA RICA. I FORGET. IT
NEEDED THE I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
A REPUTATION OF WORKING WITH
PEOPLE TO ADDRESSING ALL ISSUES
AND I'D TRY TRUST
WHOLEHEARTEDLY THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO BE DOING SO AND TRY TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD- BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT SOME OF
THESE THESE ISSUES BE ADDRESSED
AS AS YOU MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD AT ALL I'M DISAPPOINTED
TODAY BUT- SOME OF THESE
CONCERNS- YOU KNOW. WHAT
REMAINS. BUT THANK YOU.
CABALLERO THANK YOU I'M I'M I
WANT TO GREW WITH WITH MY- MY
FELLOW SENATORS HAVE TO SAY-
GIVE YOU STEPPED INTO A AN AREA
THAT'S GOT A WHOLE BUNCH OF-
LAND MINES AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. A COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT PARTIES- ONE OF THE-
THE- IT THE PIECES OF
INFORMATION I RECEIVED ABOUT
HIM IS THAT THERE ARE SOME REAL
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS TO
GROWING HEMP- AND- WELL I
HAVEN'T SEEN THE STUDIES MYSELF
IT IS REPORTED TO CLEAN THE
SOIL TO- TAKE LESS. LESS WATER-
AND SO AND TECH CLEAN THE SOIL
FROM FROM OF SALT AND HEAVY
METALS AS WHEN I WAS WHEN I WAS
TOLD- STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE IN EUROPE SO IT IT'S IN
OUR INTEREST TO LOOK AT HIM AS
A AS A PRODUCT FOR THE STATE
CALIFORNIA FOR US TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE. FOR US TO LOOK AT
WAYS FIRST BE ABLE TO USE IT
IN- IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT-
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS THAT WILL
HELP US TO RETAIN AGRICULTURE
IS PART OF OUR STATE AND ALSO
WILL HELP US TO DO
MANUFACTURING IN THE STATE AS
WELL SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TAKING THIS STEP AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HIM CONTINUING TO DO
THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS RIGHT.
THANK YOU. WELL SIR OUR CENTER
AND WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. BY I.
AM APPRECIATE THAT THE DM. THE
CONFIDENCE EXPRESSED BY THE
COMMITTEE I PERSONALLY DON'T
TAKE IT FOR GRANTED AND- LOOK
FOR TO. PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH FOLKS HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
APPRECIATE OUR CONVERSATION
MISTER CHAIR PROJECT THE-
WONDERFUL TOUR THAT THAT YOU
HAVE TO FACILITATE FOR ME AS
CENTER GLAZER. SO OFTEN AND
WHAT I WHAT I ALSO I GUESS I
WILL JUST SAY I WILL MAKE SURE
THAT MY THAT AS THIS
NEGOTIATION CONTINUES- WE WILL
MY STAFF WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP.
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE- INFORMED- AS WE MAKE
PROGRESS AND I THINK ULTIMATELY
THIS IS THIS IS ABOUT
COMPETITIVENESS I THINK OUR
FRIENDS FROM THE FARM BUREAU
RECOGNIZED THAT AND I THINK SEE
GREAT OPPORTUNITY HERE. FOR
ABLE TO LAND. A COUPLE OF THESE
GUYS DO THESE THESE KEY TRICKY
ISSUES- SO. WITH THAT I
APPRECIATE- YOUR COMMENTS AND
ASK YOU TO. ALLOW ME TO
CONTINUE DOING WORK ON THIS.
IMPORTANT MATTER AND RESPECT
FOR US FROM ABOUT. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER EGGMAN-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CAN THE ROLE
PLEASE BE CALLED. BARGES HI.
PORTICI HER TADO AYE RETARDED
AYE CABALLERO. KABIR HI EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER HIGH GLAZER
AYE ALL RIGHT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT AND I BELIEVE IT IS GOING
TO COMPLETE TODAY'S AGENDA WE
DO HAVE ONE OTHER ITEM- WE MAY
WISH TO ROOT LIFT THE CALL ON.
BECAUSE WE'RE MISSING ONE
MEMBER OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
GLAZER COPIER WAS THE ONLY. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTING
OF ITEM NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT
FIFTEEN CABALLERO COPYRIGHT BY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO ALLTHE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
POLITICS MARCH TODAY IF YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SEND ME YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
AG COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
IN ONE INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION- THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
CORPORATIONS WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON AG AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED. EVERYTHING.